accordingly consciousness in its
activity is in the first instance a
relationship of two extremes on one side
it stands as actively present while
confronting it is a passive actuality
the two sides are in a relation with one
another but both have also withdrawn
into the unchangeable and stand fast
within themselves
it is therefore only a superficial
element from each side that is involved
in the moving interplay of their mutual
opposition the passive extreme of
actuality is set aside by the active
extreme but the actuality on its side
can only be set aside because its own
unchangeable essence sets it aside
repels itself from itself and hands over
what is repelled to the active extreme
the active force appears as the power in
which actuality is dissolved for this
very reason however the consciousness to
which the intrinsic or essential being
is an other regards this power which it
displays in its activity to be the
beyond of itself instead therefore of
returning from its activity back into
itself and having obtained confirmation
of its self certainty consciousness
really reflects this activity back into
the other extreme which is thus
exhibited as a pure Universal as the
absolute power from which the activity
started in all directions and which is
the essence both of the self dividing
extremes as they at first appeared and
of their interchanging relationship
itself
paragraph 221 is going to begin with a
point that we've now seen Hegel make
many times that namely that
consciousness is in the unhappy
consciousness split into two extremes to
far-off sides that are somehow estranged
from each other and what's particularly
interesting in this paragraph is the
language that he's going to use now he's
going to talk in terms of activity and
passivity and the English translation
that Miller is is providing there's just
a little bit misleading but we'll get to
that in just a moment
he's also framing this in such a way
that should bring us back to what was
going on in force of the understanding
and the interplay between forces the
reciprocity and the question of you know
who took the initiative first and was
the person who took the force that took
the initiative actually being allowed
that initiative because the other force
was allowing it the whole event is worth
keeping in mind so this is one of those
those passages where the previous
dialectical developments that we went
through if we thought through it and we
worked through it and we kept it in our
mind and we didn't just forget about it
so random getting to a better
destination helps us to understand
what's going on here particularly in not
only this paragraph but the paragraph to
follow so he says that on the two sides
we have one that is consciousness as an
active and I'm translating this as
presence Miller actually he has you're
actively present the German is tenth
occur these sites right these sites is
on this side or or you know what is
present to us
waiting's nights as we've said before is
the opposite to that the far off the
beyond is how it's being being
translated in the English now ten
together is coming from from the the
word for doing and taht is you could say
Nietzsche actually makes quite a bit out
of this and
discussion of that very term Todd is
kind of an unusual word because it's a
noun but it's not really a substantive
it is a doing it is active you can
translate it as act right and when we
say in the word act in Latin Octus you
know in French that's right
there's there's a weirdness about that
because it's not like boy a book is
something solid you can hold in your
hand or person act by its very nature is
something active it's it's doing it's
acting it's engaging right so there is
this this dynamic side the active
presence and then there is another side
passive actuality now the term act
showing up in both of them might make us
think that you know what was being
played out here is the similarity
between them the German for that is
pasta pasta
verily we've encountered this word
really quite a lot
reality actuality you know what's there
and it's being contrasted to the active
this side and there's two ways in which
this is happening in this passage Hegel
is going to contrast a superficial
relationship between the two of them
over flocking is is the term there and
their relationship as they are in the
unchangeable instead of one of these
sides being a changeable both of them
are what they are for consciousness and
also what they are in the unchangeable
so there's kind of a double sided
opposition going on here because
remember consciousness is trying to make
sense out of the unchangeable which
actually is consciousness so he goes on
enemy says on the one side it's actively
present confronted as the packs of
actuality they are in relation with each
other but both have also withdrawn into
the unchangeable and stand fast in
themselves they have an essence right
and now I've got essence on this side
over here and on this
however much but you can also think of
the the power as being a sense of this
polarity so how does this work
he says the passive extreme of actuality
is set aside by the active extreme and
the setting aside here is of Abell it is
you know sublation it is transcending it
is you know annulling it so in a certain
way the activity the initiative is
coming from the side understandably
enough of the active against the passive
here's where it resembles force on the
understanding right and so many other
dentists so within the essence of the
passive actuality yet as he says repels
itself from itself this is that self
uttering that we've seen happen so many
times throughout the phenomenology and
that is what allows the active side to
receive to be receptive to the passive
actuality it is handing itself over it a
lot that's what allows this out able to
take place so these two parts are
actually reciprocal to each other
he says the actual reality can only be
set aside because its own essence set to
the side that tells itself from itself
and hands over what is repelled to the
active extreme so the active extreme is
not the solely active thing he says the
active force appears as the power the
mocked in German in which actuality is
dissolved now that there again you see
the ambiguity of the English the power
in which vehicle a kite is dissolved
he says for this very reason the
consciousness to which the intrinsic or
essential being is an other right
consciousness has been trying to make
sense of this whole mass and it keeps on
projecting things outside of itself not
realizing that in itself is grasping
them regard
this power bunch of displays and its
activity to be the beyond so the D
sights the here on this side of things
the hey I've got this now suddenly
becomes the Yang's lights the beyond the
thing that's that's you know forever
deluding consciousness even though it's
within the the realm and the grasp of
consciousness so he goes on he says
what's the upshot of this instead of
returning from its activity back into
itself and obtaining confirmation of
itself certainty grasping all of this as
itself instead of that consciousness
reflects this activity back into the
other extreme which is thus exhibited as
a pure Universal of power again you can
see the play of forces at work don't
know the problem with this he says it's
an absolute power from which the
activity started in all directions so
what we got going on here
the activity on the part of
consciousness is now revealed as having
had its ground or its its initiative or
its causality if you would like to say
it that way from something that lies
outside of consciousness that could be
another consciousness could just be a
blank force it's a universal and it
doesn't have full activity in itself
actuality is over here right now we're
just talking about the activity so we
think of activity itself is being sort
unconditioned spontaneous free applying
to other things but it's really being
conditioned itself consciousness is
really doing all of this but doesn't
realize it so there is this this bar
that is occurring at this division and
he goes out and he says this is the
essence both of the self dividing
extremes as they first appeared and uh
they're interchanging relationship
itself so consciousness is May
a kind of fundamental mistake
consciousness is really responsible for
all of us but it is taking instead this
as being responsible for all of this and
consciousness is just sort of lost in
the mix or in the mess
the fact that the unchangeable
consciousness rut announces and
surrenders its embodied form while on
the other hand the particular individual
consciousness gives thanks for the gift
that is denies itself the satisfaction
of being conscious of its independence
and assigns the essence of its action
not to itself but to the beyond through
these two moments of reciprocal self
surrender of both parts consciousness
does of course gain a sense of its unity
with the unchangeable but these unity is
at the same time affected with division
is again broken within itself and from
it there emerges once more the
antithesis of the universal and of the
individual for although consciousness
renounces the show of satisfying its
feeling of self it obtains the actual
satisfaction of it for it has been and
desire work and enjoyment as
consciousness it has willed acted and
enjoyed similarly even its giving of
thanks in which it acknowledges the
other extreme is the essential being
inconstant self nothing is its own Act
which counterbalance is the action of
the other extreme and meets the
self-sacrificing beneficence with a like
action if the other extreme delivers
over to consciousness only the surface
of its being yet consciousness also
gives thanks and in surrendering its own
an action that is its essential being it
really does more than the other which
only sheds a superficial element of
itself thus the entire movement is
reflected not only in the actual
desiring working and enjoyment but even
in the very giving of thanks where the
reverse seems to take place in the
extreme of individuality consciousness
feels itself therein as this particular
individual and does not let itself be
deceived by its own seeming renunciation
for the truth of the matter is that it
is not renounced itself what has been
brought about is only the double
reflection into the two extremes and the
results is the renewed division into the
opposed consciousness of the
unchangeable and the consciousness of
willing performing and enjoying and
Sofra nunciature which confronts it in
other words the consciousness of
independent individuality in general
something very interesting is happening
and coming to the fore in paragraph 222
this is a fairly long paragraph and if
you had put it in one word it's this
giving thanks I've got at the top here
that what Hegel is exploring is the
relationship which is in a certain way
reciprocity in a certain way non
reciprocal between gift and gratitude
and we want to remember back just a few
paragraphs before we are we were talking
about how the individual consciousness
the end of the dual human being as a
particular is able to do things that
faculties allow them to do to think for
example to desire to to work and Hegel
had said that these faculties themselves
are something different although not
totally separate from the activities of
those faculties and those faculties
themselves are gifts and if I remember
right I said back then you know keep
that in your back pocket because that's
going to be important this is the
paragraph where this becomes very
important at least in this section so
there's a relationship between gift and
gratitude that he's exploring here which
is also a relationship between
independence and dependence the one who
gives the gift one way you can think of
this does so not out of any sort of
coercion or out of any need their part
that's what makes it a gift rather than
just merely a transaction I give you
this so you give me that reason we're
give here in a different way when we
talk about something being grabbed to
access right we're talking about that
element of the gift as being totally
uncoerced it doesn't have to happen and
in a certain sense if we think about
this in a metaphysical way it doesn't
have a clause except for perhaps the
goodness of the giver or the choice of
the giver now on the other side
gratitude
occur without the giving of a gratuitous
gift right they don't have thankfulness
before there's anything to thank
somebody for and the gratitude itself is
one handed action right one one can show
gratitude or not show gratitude but on
the other hand it's kind of a reaction
it is a results from a passivity you
don't have to be given it yes if you got
everything that you need anyway right
and when you really are grateful what
you're saying is something like I
couldn't have provided this for myself I
am dependent so hateful is going to say
now within the unity and unconsciousness
with the unchangeable that we've been
talking about so far there is an
interesting interplay that's taking
place here we have a particular
individual consciousness on one side we
have the unchangeable consciousness
which is going to be the universal the
other side and we have a giving and a
receiving on both parts as Hinkle's
going to call it with this very nice
turn of phrase reciprocal self surrender
of both parts right there and this this
is really quite important this is not
just giving something extrinsic to
oneself like I give you a Hegel book you
know I send it to you in the mail or
something like that
you know many thanks here you go I hope
you enjoy the point instead it's giving
something out of one's very being or or
essence the universal unchangeable
consciousness we see this before a
previous paragraph renounces or
surrenders area it's embodied form its
Gestalt we've seen this already
discussed now we're seeing the upshot of
that it could just routine that
embodiment or in individuality in and of
itself but instead knowing it accords
that it gives it to the many individuals
the a particular consciousness the
existing people
that's giving up something of itself
what can the individual consciousness
give in return well they can give things
and in the giving of things there is a
sort of confession going on
he says the particular individual
consciousness gives thanks for the gift
and what this amounts to is denying
itself the satisfaction of being
conscious of its independence in giving
thanks in in acknowledging having
received something from from the
universal it forgets
well it doesn't know that it itself is
the universal because it's consciousness
but it forgets then it itself is
independent what's going to happen in
the rest of this paragraph is the
recovery of that independence
interestingly enough in the very heart
of the what appears to be totally
dependent the gratitude for the gift so
let's go on he says what happens is
consciousness gains a sense of its unity
with the unchangeable through this
interplay but it's a unity that's broken
there's there's a division there right
he says it's broken within itself from
and again there emerges once more the
antithesis of the individual and the
universal so how do we get past this
he says for though consciousness
renounces the show is satisfying it's
feeling something it obtains the actual
satisfaction now that's a strange
transition isn't it that's like hitting
oh saying well we're going this way now
to totally turn her home to this way
right why well that's all this stuff
down here he says that it has been
desire and work and enjoyment right it
attains the actual satisfaction of its
feeling of self why because it has been
desire work and enjoy
not just in a purely individual way but
in a more universal way it has willed
right gevalt acted gathon and enjoyed or
as another translation of this has it
consumed good Olsen so in doing these
things that engage us with the world
they aren't just in our heads that
aren't just keeping us in isolation
these things that are that are you might
say tangible relations we become aware
of our own independence and as a subject
and you know independence does not lie
just on this side you could say okay
that's fine you're you're becoming aware
of yourself is an independent subject
but still you don't you're not the
source of your being
you're not the source of your faculties
you I have to acknowledge yourself as a
dependent creature so the question that
we can ask that is well what about this
thanking business here's where he'll is
going to turn thanking you might say
upside down
thanking at this point gratitude which
was showing dependence now thanking is
going to become without ceasing to be
dependence a source of independence he
says in its giving of thanks in which it
acknowledges the other stream as the
essential being and counts itself
nothing this is still its own act this
is still its own doing he says it is its
only act which counterbalance is the
action of the other extreme and meets
the self-sacrificing beneficence with a
light action gratitude in a certain
sense elevates us into a state of not
being totally independent as in being
disconnected from another thing which is
likewise independent being totally
undefended parameter it elevates us to
the level of the independence and we
realize that genuine independence
includes a kind of
conforth reciprocity Hagel is actually
showing us that independence doesn't
preclude the you know the relationship
between gift giver and receiver and
gratitude who is also when we say one is
giving thanks that is also a giving
right so this is quite profound stuff
that's going on here in this passage he
says if the other extreme delivers over
to consciousness only the surface of its
being yet consciousness also gives
things and is surrendering its own
action with all this other stuff that is
it's essential being it really does more
it in the act in a greater way there's
greater agency or activity on the side
of what appears to be dependent the
Thanksgiving then on the side of the one
who gave so he goes on he says the
entire movement is reflected not only in
the actual desiring and working and
enjoyment but even in the giving of
thanks thanks is something like these
modalities these these things that that
involve our being as human beings as
social beings as individuals willing
acting enjoying or consuming giving
thanks as is just as you might say
anthropologically or even if you want to
talk about say the metaphysics of the
human person just as metaphysically
basic just as metaphysically essential
and fundamental as all of this other
stuff this is a fascinating insight
isn't it that Hegel is working out here
he's going to conclude by telling us
that consciousness feels itself therein
as this particular individual does not
let itself be deceived by its own
seeming renunciation but the truth of
the matter is it is not renounced itself
what has been brought about is this
double reflection the the renewed
division into the opposed consciousness
of the unchangeable and the
consciousness of willing performing and
enjoying
and the self renunciation that is
thanking again which confronts it in
other words the consciousness of
independent individuality in general so
what is going on the particular
individual has actually come to the
point of realizing itself as
individuality in general because of its
own agency in desiring working enjoying
and even thinking now it's still of
course this is a complex thing it's
receiving that from what is over here
the universal individual you could say
our individuality in general
individuality individuality in general
has given itself over now to the
particular universe the particular
individual who has been able to receive
it precisely through this experience